صبا المتظاهرون في ايران ومعهم بعض
الاصلاحين غضبهم على المرشد منذ دلاع
الاحتجاجات في الشارع الايراني
لكنهم تجنبوا الرئيس الايراني استثناء
رئيسي لم يغضب النظام بل على العكس من ذلك
بحسب صحيفه خاينز والابتعاد عن مهاجمه
رئيسي يعني عدم مهاجمه الحكومه وبالتالي
فهي لن تكون مضطره الى تقديم تنازلات بحسب
الصحيفه التي رات ان ابتعاد الرئيس
الايراني عن الواجهه يناسب القياده
الايرانيه حتى وان صبغ غضب المحتجين على
خامسه
كيهان التابعه لمرشد ايران اقرت بسخط
المتظاهرين على خامنه مشيره الى ان
المحتاجين لم يهتفوا بشعارات ضد اي سياسي
اخر
اقرار فسره البعض لانه محاوله من خامنئي
للافاده من ذلك في تقويه سلطته من خلال
اقناع السياسيين بانه راس الحربه في
الدفاع عن النظام
ومع اتساع غضب الشارع الايراني على النظام
ورموزه يوما بعد يوم يحاول النظام بكل
الطرق ايجاد مخرج باستخدام القوه او
بغيرها لايقاف مد هذه التظاهرات المستمر